some have argued that Africa's recent
economic boom is a short-term
development
brought on by rising commodity prices
that will inevitably fall while others
see it as a signal of a new era of
growth for the continent where do you
fall in this debate and what do you
predict for Africa's economic future
well I believe that there is something
fundamentally important going on in
Africa as it is in the emerging world if
you look at data on GDP growth it's
really all regions of the world that
have shown growth substantial growth in
recent decades it's it's not a sudden
short-lived phenomenon it's it's a
long-lasting phenomenon and it's not
confined to the oil-rich countries I
believe that it's more due to a spirit
that's a knowledge that is spreading
around the world the world is more built
around financial capitalism than ever
before we're opening up stock markets
all over the world venture capital firms
are starting to practice in countries
where such a thing was unheard of
entrepreneurship is being encouraged
young people all over the world in every
country of the world are interested in
becoming entrepreneurs and there's an
understanding today that
entrepreneurship is where economic
growth begins you see this in Africa
you'll see this in the Middle East and
Latin America Asia all of the emerging
world is to varying extents but to a
substantial extent participating in what
I think historians will someday describe
is a historically important transition
so it's much broader than commodities
that's correct
and even those commodity rich countries
that are running out of oil these days
are actually many of them starting
sovereign wealth funds because they're
aware that they're going to run out of
oil and so instead of just consuming all
the oil
they are investing for the future which
is a which is a quite a increase step
forward in enlightenment that we've seen
over the last decade or two is it's it's
a growing phenomenon that people are
appreciating that you have to lock down
secure the wealth and not go through it
fast that's part of Finance